battles have been won against greater
odds
I fought beyond the wall against worse
than Ramsey Bob you don't know him
if a fool don't bring me back thousands
of men don't need to die
only one of us
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my episode 9 trailer video Battle of
the bastards bastard bowls Noble
whatever you want to call it let's break
it down there's a couple really notable
things that are going on here you may
have detected a very Braveheart vibe
where in John Snow William Wallace's
force is very small
totally outmatched by Ramsay's forces
and I've seen a lot of you real world
history buffs hoping that there's a
Battle of Northampton situation which is
basically what happened at the end of
Braveheart where a giant portion of one
of the armies made a secret deal to lay
down arms and allow the opposing side
through so a lot of people have hoped
that part of Ramsay's army will lay down
arms and flip sides in the middle of the
battle but if you haven't watched a
Braveheart in a long time that happened
before the battle started William
Wallace had been on this tear with his
army they had been destroying all the
king's centers of powers until this big
final battle where the King made a
secret deal with part of Wallace's army
they lay down arms and that's ultimately
what led to Wallace's downfall
so you basically wound up with this
giant imbalance between the size of the
both armies like look at Ramsay's army
here this looks like a much more
traditional formation you have rows of
archers you have pikemen you have
mounted soldiers just look how deep they
are and then you look at Jon Snow's army
like you see one one here running
through the foreground they have some of
the wildlings they have a handful of the
Mormont's and it's really hard to pick
out which banners exactly these are
because the TV show has swapped some of
the colors on some of the other houses
banners so we'll just have to wait for
the episode to get better shots of all
these but using the TV shows a logic
behind mass transit I think we can
assume that in the episodes that we
haven't seen Jon Snow and Sansa did a
few more people from other houses of the
north had joined the army but it's still
just a handful of people compared to
what Ramsay has so I think the show
wants you to believe that it's a
Braveheart situation and we all know how
that ended Jon Snow even tells
Melisandre if I fall in battle don't
bring me back again so they're just
they're teasing you with this Braveheart
situation when Sansa has gone behind Jon
Snow's back to send Littlefinger a
letter I know it was a very clear who
she was writing to but there have been
people who have decoded part of sauces
letter she's basically telling
Littlefinger okay you're trash but I
need your help anyway so given how
melancholy everyone looks on this
battlefield all these dead bodies all
over the place I think it's going to be
an eleventh-hour
Littlefinger's say but you guys can let
me know do you think that Sansa wrote to
Littlefinger that was the secret letter
because she wasn't writing to the
blackfish she had already sent Brienne
to get the black fish's help before she
sent the other letter in the more recent
episode so the person she was writing to
was different from the blackfish so
given that do you think that she was
asking for Littlefinger self and they'll
come riding in just in time to save our
precious main characters but not before
a ton of people end up dying and I know
a lot of you have wondered if in the
background some of these figures are the
night's king or White Walkers if they're
going to walk in and interrupt the
battle I'm not expecting that twist
because I think we'll follow up with
them with bran storyline so unless we
see bran in this episode I'm not
expecting to see White Walkers south of
the wall I think the surprise is going
to be the Knights of the Vale but the
other big question because there isn't
any other footage besides this battle of
the bastards in the trailer is will we
see Daenerys in the second siege of
murine or are they going to save that
for the last episode
even though hardhome was a massive
episode of last season they still
touched on a couple other storylines
even though they spent most of the
episode up at hardhome
so I think that might be the case here
where most of the episode takes place at
the Battle of Winterfell but they
briefly touch on the other storylines so
even if we don't get to see Daenerys
release the other two dragons till
episode 10
I think the Lee's briefly touch on that
storyline and then we also have Cersei
in the promise of a mad Queen situation
with wildfire so if they don't touch on
that then they'll be saving that for
episode 10 but I love how we've all been
joking about Daenerys Mad Queen when we
should really be talking about Cersei
mad Queen even though technically she's
the Queen Mother but here's my other big
question for you guys
let me know do you feel like it's going
to be Snowbowl episode 9 and then it's
going to be fire in episode 10 because
we have Cersei wildfire that might be
happening and we have Daenerys as
Dragons versus the great masters so
there are a couple of big battles some
of them involving fire some of them
taking place in the frozen north but
that's to say nothing of what bran is
going to do when the night's king's army
reaches the wall that's like a
completely separate situation than from
what's going on here at Winterfell so be
prepared for them to touch on that
briefly but there's just so many things
that they have to resolve that I'll be
interested to see what they leave out of
episode 9 because there are at least
three big battles coming to a head four
if you count brand versus the night's
king
but my next big video is gonna be my QA
from episode 8 I'm happy to answer
questions about episode 9 to just leave
all your questions on this there is a
new round of the giveaway that's still
going on all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video I'll just announce the winner
whenever I post that Q&A video so
that'll be Tuesday or Wednesday I feel
like if you thought episode 8 was
lackluster this is the answer to that
just pitch battle for an entire episode
it's gonna be so much fun
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for last night's
episode 8 video and you can click here
for a tower of joy or plus L equals J
refresher if you guys don't know what
that's all about thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight